good afternoon everyone I'm Peter
Saliva's the president of Yale
University
you know I love the fact that that line
still gets Gathers applause you know
there's there will come a day when it
won't well on behalf of the trustees of
Yale University the faculty and everyone
here at Yale and in the New Haven
community it's my honor to introduce
Ambassador Samantha power ambassador
power is here on campus today as a chubb
fellow hand and job was a 1895 graduate
of Yale's Sheffield scientific school
and in 1936 he made a substantial gift
to the university to encourage our
students to take an interest in public
service since 1949 his endowment has
been used to underwrite a prestigious
visiting speakers program bringing
extraordinary public figures to the
campus the fellowship is administered by
the master of timothy dwight college who
is currently jeffrey burns l who you
will see later in the program past Chubb
fellows have included four presidents of
the United States presidents of eight
other countries and more than 150 other
regionally nationally and
internationally prominent individuals
noted for their distinction in service
to the common good I'm especially
delighted to introduce ambassador power
today for two reasons first we are
celebrating her homecoming she earned
her bachelor's degree in history from
Yale in 1992 and I found that one of the
great pleasures
I don't know if those are all the
history majors or the class of 1992 but
we found one of the greatest pleasures
and privileges in the Yale presidency is
the opportunity to welcome back
graduates who have distinguished
themselves in the world in this
particular case I confess to having a
personal stake in the outcome
ambassador power was a student in my
psychology class I thought I don't know
whether she has been able to apply
anything that she actually learned in
that class in the years since but I'm
happy now perhaps happier that she might
have been at the time to make careful
note of the fact that she was one of my
students the second reason is it is a
special pleasure to welcome ambassador
Power today is that collectively
yellos her a debt of gratitude I would
put it this way she has chosen to do
with her life what we aspire to prepare
all of our students to do she has taken
maximal advantage both here and
elsewhere of the privileged educational
opportunities that her capacities and
circumstances presented to her and she
has fully embraced these opportunities
in order to accomplish extraordinary
things both with respect to the life of
the mind and to the life of the world
most of you know that ambassador Power
has combined in an unusual and powerful
way the careers of an academic and a
public servant while in law school at
Harvard she began writing a paper that
became her appellate surprise winning an
immensely influential book a problem
from hell America and the age of
genocide published in 2002 it has been
said of this book that it influenced
more young people and in particular more
women to devote themselves to studying
and working in human rights than any
work published before or since in an
often told story we know that the book
also moved the then junior senator from
Illinois Barack Obama to meet her for
dinner from there her story accelerates
staff member to Senator Obama foreign
policy advisor to the presidential
campaign special assistant to the
President and Senior Director
multilateral affairs and Human Rights
u.s. permanent representative to the
United Nations the youngest-ever at age
43 and throughout her rapid rise to
positions of accountability and
influence Samantha power has
demonstrated a remarkable commitment to
probing the often troubling relationship
between the prerogatives of power and
the obligations of power here at Yale we
were grateful and honored to have her as
a member of our community where once she
came to study in our classrooms today
she has returned to offer us her own
instruction and wisdom please join me in
extending to her our own warm welcome
back to yell bastard
this is not the Welcome I get when I
walk into the UN Security Council every
morning
I should come here more often it is it's
wonderful truly wonderful very moving
for me to be back
I came to Yale from Atlanta Georgia I
went to a public high school in Atlanta
Georgia and being here it is no
overstatement to say that being here
completely changed my life it was an
amazing experience many of my teachers
are here who I still think about even as
I do my day job I went from wanting to
be a sportscaster which would have been
a very worthy career and still I pine
for it at times to wanting to do
something anything in American foreign
policy because of the the the teaching
and the inspiration that I got from the
Yale faculty and from my fellow
classmates I will say that I never ever
ever ever imagined that I would come
back to Yale to speak as the UN
Ambassador so it's thrilling for me
thank you we are living in a time it is
very fair to say of daunting and
perpetual crises the deadly spread of
Ebola in West Africa a string of
shocking executions by ISIL more tanks
and heavy armaments rolling across
Ukraine's border two Russian backed
separatists barrel bombs and chlorine
being dropped by the Assad regime on
Syrian civilians child soldiers being
abducted and forced to fight in a brutal
civil war in the world's newest country
South Sudan the list goes on and on
there's so many crises that when we turn
our attention to working to bring one of
these under control or trying to reduce
the suffering that a particular crisis
is causing two more pop up at a
different time in our history we may
have felt tempted to ignore some of
these threats we may have thought that
we wouldn't pay a price in 1776 Thomas
Paine
that quote America remote from all the
wrangling of the world may live at ease
bounded by the ocean and backed by the
wilderness what hath she to fear but her
God
end quote but in today's interconnected
world we don't have the luxury of
remoteness from the world's wrangling it
can impact us more swiftly and more
deeply than ever before now this is not
news to any of you you see it you feel
it you understand that America cannot
afford to ignore these threats and at
the same time you understand that
today's threats are so immense and so
complex that even if the United States
wanted to tackle any one of them alone
we would not be able to do so we need to
rally the international community to our
side
the point I want to make to you today is
that in addition to leading the
international community in responding to
these threats in real time we need to
help shape a world where such threats
are like less likely to arise in the
first place
this sounds so obvious I know and yet
generations of policymakers across the
political spectrum have struggled to
dedicate the bandwidth financial
resources and diplomatic and political
capital to make these long-term
investments as someone who came into
government fully convinced of the
critical importance of seeing beyond the
crisis of the moment I can tell you that
it is surprisingly challenging in
practice to do so given all else but my
message to you today is that we cannot
treat the short and long term as an
either/or proposition we have to try to
put out a lot of fires in the here and
now but we can't let the immediacy of
today's crises distract us from playing
a smart long game that will create more
stability and more security in the long
run let me offer a few examples curbing
the spread of Ebola protecting the
rights of women and girls and countering
violent extremism on September 18th the
United States chaired the first-ever
emergency meeting of the UN Security
Council
on a public health crisis Ebola by that
time more than 2,500 people had died of
the virus and some 5,500 had been
reported infected in Guinea Liberia and
Sierra Leone a Liberian health care
worker named Jackson Neama who was
working at medicines on frontier Ebola
clinic in the capital of Monrovia spoke
to the council via videolink he
described people dying outside the gates
of the clinic where he worked because
there were just no more beds to take
them in he said quote I feel that the
future of my country is hanging in the
balance if the international community
does not stand up we will be wiped out
and quote now the United States has done
more than any other country to help West
Africa respond to the Ebola crisis the
CDC deployed teams to the region way
back in March shortly after the outbreak
began in July President Obama declared
controlling the epidemic and national
security priority and most importantly
days before that September Security
Council meeting the president announced
the largest Global Health intervention
in US history resulting so far in the
deployment of more than 3,000 US
civilian and military personnel from the
Department of Defense US aid the CDC and
other agencies we're supporting the
construction of 15 a bola treatment
units so called et use and brave and
brilliant men and women in the US Public
Health Service commissioned Corps
provide Ebola treatment at a 25-bed
hospital built by the US military and
dedicated to treating health care
workers and Ebola responders who
contract the virus this ensures that
medical volunteers and UN personnel from
around the world will receive top-notch
care if they are infected while working
on the frontlines of this epidemic the
United States is training hundreds of
Liberian health care workers at a newly
built Center in Monrovia and countless
more through mobile training teams
traveling to remote areas but even with
all this we know that the United States
alone cannot curb the epidemics deadly
spread that's why we mobilized
133 other countries the most in the
history of the United Nations to
co-sponsor a Security Council resolution
declaring Ebola a threat to
international peace and security
it's why President Obama personally
launched a full-court press to mobilize
commitments from other countries
keeping heads of state around the world
on speed-dial to convince them to do
more and it is why we are now holding
other countries to the commitments that
they have made and pressing those who
have committed too little or who've
committed nothing at all to do their
part because we will not defeat Ebola
with some hands on deck effort having
visited the most affected countries at
the end of October I can tell you that
we are beginning to see the impact of
our collective response in Bonn County
Liberia I visited a US Navy run Ebola
testing lab which had cut the time local
Liberians waited for test results from
five days to between three and five
hours on November fourth only 33 out of
53 Ebola affected districts across the
region had the ability to transport
samples to a lab within 24 hours of
collecting them according to the w-h-o
by November 17th just 13 days later all
53 districts had that capability and lab
testing time matters because the sooner
you get your results the sooner you can
leave facilities where you might be
waiting with people who are actually
infected and in many of these labs about
70% of the results are coming back
negative so actually a large number of
people who are being tested are not
those who in fact have a bowl they may
have malaria they may have some other
ailment that allows them to leave and it
frees up bed space for those who need to
be isolated with Ebola the results
affirm what we have said all along about
Ebola which is that we know how to win
this fight we can bend ebolas deadly
curve but bending that curve is very
different from ending it it would be a
huge mistake to think that just because
we are seeing signs of progress in some
areas that we are close to stopping this
outbreak we are not in Sierra Leone the
disease is spreading faster than at any
time
since the outbreak began with more than
900 new infections reported in the
two-week period that ended November 23rd
some 16,000 people have been reported
infected in West Africa and more than
5,500 people have died the actual
figures are likely in fact to be much
higher local contact tracing teams
outside of capitals which are critical
to breaking chains of transmission
continue to lack basic resources like
gas for their motorcycles or even credit
for their SIM cards on their cell phones
and the human toll is staggering think
for a second about the heartbreak
associated with any one of the 4,000
boys and girls who have lost a mother or
father to the virus 4000 orphans or the
incalculable loss of warmth in countries
where people used to hug when they met
but now are told not to wipe the tears
from the eyes of a sick child in case
the child might be infected or the pain
experienced by the people who have
beaten the virus only to find themselves
stigmatized or even run out of town by
their friends and their communities when
they attempt to go home yet in spite of
all the suffering the outbreak has
caused and it is immense and in spite of
the virus's surge in parts of the
affected countries we have to find a way
to look beyond the outbreak and ask what
factors made these countries so
vulnerable we have to take steps now so
that in the long term we avoid finding
ourselves in this situation again one
reasonably spread so fast was because
West Africa had never experienced an
Ebola outbreak before and even before
the virus surfaced public health systems
in Guinea Liberia and Sierra Leone were
stretched beyond capacity just to meet
the day-to-day needs of their citizens
prior to the outbreak Liberia had
approximately 50 doctors for the entire
country of 4.3 million people that's
around one doctor for every 100,000
people Sierra Leone had two doctors for
every 100,000 people the United States
by contrast has 245 doctors for every
100,000 people the United Kingdom has
279 Germany 3
hundred and eighty Yale New Haven
Hospital which is just one of nearly 50
hospitals in kinetic alone has more than
600 resident physicians Liberian 50
before Ebola the Yale New Haven number
is 12 times the number of doctors in all
of pre bola Liberia the Yale School of
Medicine graduates over 10 times the
number of doctors in a single class then
worked in Liberia before Ebola began
taking some of the country's best nurses
and doctors Ebola has killed
approximately 330 health care workers in
West Africa many of whom were not
working to treat Ebola when they were
infected but rather were providing
routine medical assistance such as
delivering babies the affected countries
also lacked and in many instances
continued to lack protective suits and
even plastic gloves to keep health care
workers safe they lack lab capacity
emergency operation centers and disease
surveillance systems communities were
not aware and some are still not aware
of what a bola is or how it is spread
all of these deficiencies meant that
when the Ebola outbreak hit these
countries it hit harder and spread
faster leaders and communities in the
region understand the importance of
plugging these gaps they understand the
dangerous shorten sightedness of
thinking our job is done when we end the
current outbreak they know what
epidemiologists research proves another
outbreak weather of Ebola or of another
deadly disease like SARS or MERS is
inevitable but whether these outbreaks
become full-blown epidemics is up to us
when I met with President Ellen Johnson
Sirleaf in Liberia on my trip to the
region and asked her what keeps her up
at night she said it was the country's
Restless youth three-quarters of
Liberia's population is under the age of
35
she said she worried about kids who've
been out of school for months about
young men and women who've lost their
jobs since Liberia's economy started its
ongoing decline one out of every two
Liberians
who was employed at the
beginning of the outbreak is now out of
work seven in ten people surveyed said
they do not have enough money to buy
food
president Conde of Guinea and President
Koroma of Sierra Leone voice similar
concerns so did so many of the community
and civil society leaders I met with in
all three countries they were worried
that making it to Ebola free will
quickly translate into these countries
being assistance free as we in the
international community quickly pack up
and leave behind countries with far
greater insecurity and far weaker
economies with thousands of orphans
children and public institutions in
shambles recognising these acute risks
we are now looking beyond ending this
Ebola epidemics curve to preventing the
next infectious disease epidemic back in
February before the first cases of Ebola
in Guinea came to light the United
States launched the global health
security agenda the GHSA the agendas
aimed at preparing countries to prevent
detect and rapidly respond to outbreaks
before they become epidemics during a
meeting with President Obama in
September 43 countries joined us in
announcing over 100 specific commitments
to strengthen global health security
together with the w-h-o and other
international institutions the GHSA is
predicated on the understanding that in
a world where an outbreak that begins in
the forests of Guinea can quickly spread
across borders continents and even
oceans a weakness in any part of our
interconnected global health security
system is a threat to us all we and our
partners have set out 11 areas of focus
to strengthen national regional and
global capacity these include boosting
immunization rates to stop the
resurgence of preventable diseases
ensuring countries have nationwide lab
systems capable of conducting rapid
accurate tests to detect outbreaks early
and developing and implementing the real
time disease surveillance systems and
the workforce required to track
outbreaks like the contact tracing teams
that are so critical to tracking down
those who might have had physical
contact with someone infected with Ebola
each area focused within the GHSA has a
five year implementation plan which sets
out concrete benchmarks along the way
and a way to measure them to meet crises
head-on where they are we are also
developing new regional partners such as
the African Union's own Centers for
Disease Control which the AU and the
United States agreed to jointly create
during this year's us-africa leaders
summit and our own CDC is helping to
advise and build we're also investing in
the young policymakers innovators and
civil society leaders who will lead
their countries in responding not only
to this kind of crisis but other crises
whether inside or outside of government
these individuals will do the yeoman's
work of shoring up institutions and
making societies more resilient and less
vulnerable to global threats like
epidemics this is why President Obama
launched the young African leaders
initiative which brought its first class
of 500 Mandela Washington fellows to the
United States to study this past summer
20 of our nation's top universities
including Yale I'm proud to say hosted
Mandela Washington fellows for six weeks
of leadership training skill building
and networking with their peers some of
you in the audience may have had the
chance to hear from these fellows about
their remarkable work often done in the
most daunting circumstances one of the
Mandela Washington fellows in this
year's class was Sarah McGill a 28 year
old Liberian when Sarah returned home
this fall she noticed a problem because
of the exponential spread of Ebola when
Sarah went shopping in Monrovia all the
stores had signs outside telling people
to wash their hands in chlorinated water
before entering most shops had a five
liter bucket outside and at the busier
businesses the wait could take up to ten
minutes during that time people crowded
into long lines when they were at
greater risk of infection others gave up
and left costing the stores business so
Sarah designed a simple 440 liter tank
with six individual stations which
permit multiple people to wash their
hands at once
and cuz the tank is much larger it only
needs to be refilled once a day as
opposed to every few hours with smaller
buckets 16 communities are now using
this simple tank that Sarah designed and
more plan to build them particularly
outside of schools enabling potentially
schools to open back up and the
necessary precautions to be put in place
investing in a problem solver like Sarah
and all of the young problem solvers in
this audience tonight has to be part of
our long game now I've been on campus
for about two and a half hours and I've
already gotten an administration's worth
of policy recommendations today from
Yale students and faculty thank you for
that but let me offer one to you and to
take advantage of the leadership who is
present here today I would urge you not
only to host future classes of Bend Ella
Washington fellows but also to deepen
your engagement with the initiative by
sending Yale students faculty members
and researchers out into the field to
partner with the fellows who have
studied here Dartmouth which also hosted
fellows in 2014 has started a program
like this and its first batch of
students are on their way to Tanzania
Ghana Angola and Zimbabwe to work with
fellows this winter of course
Ebola is not the only crisis where it is
in America's interests and the world's
to play the long game even as we respond
to immediate threats another is
advancing the rights of women and girls
we've got to address the immediate
crisis of widespread gender-based
violence particularly in wartime while
at the same time making the crucial
long-term investments in the empowerment
of women and girls
violence against women during conflicts
is anything but a new problem one of the
earliest accounts of the mass abduction
of women and girls can be found in
Plutarch's parallel lives where the
seizure of saben women played a central
part in the creation of Rome Plutarch
wrote armed with swords then many of
Romulus as followers kept their eyes
intently upon him and when the signal
was given drew their swords rushed in
with shouts and ravished away
of the say Bynes some say that only 30
maidens were seized and that from these
the curiae were named but valeria s--
anteus puts the number at 527 and Juba
at 683 all maidens we know that violence
against women and girls in conflicts
persists with disturbing frequency yet
the statistics and the horrifying
individual acts continue to shock
consider the Democratic Republic of
Congo where sexual violence has long
been used as a tactic of war in the
decades-long conflict in one of the most
devastating incidents at least 387
people including three hundred women and
55 girls were raped by armed groups in
13 villages in eastern Congo between
July 30th and August 2nd 2010 just a
three-day period while conflicts
exacerbate such violence it is a daily
fact of life for women and girls around
the world one in three women is the
victim of physical or sexual violence in
their lifetimes the UN estimates that a
hundred and fifty million girls
worldwide experienced sexual violence
each year in Sao Paulo Brazil is largest
city a woman is assaulted every 15
seconds according to UN Women and in
many places the problem is getting worse
not better in Honduras the number of
violent deaths of women increased by two
hundred and sixty three percent from
2005 to 2013
yet in 95 percent of sexual violence
crimes and killings of women in Honduras
the perpetrators are never punished
there are immediate steps we can take to
stop violence against women and girls
both during conflicts and in peacetime
we can improve accountability for
violence against women and girls through
strengthening documentation of abuses
and the capacity of justice officials to
prosecute perpetrators physicians for
Human Rights created a mobile app Medi
capped which it piloted this year in the
Congo and which converts standardized
medical intake forms into a way to
gather forensic documentation for
prosecutions when a medical professional
fills out the form using the app it is
immediately turned into a digital record
which can be used by prosecutors
- trace patterns and bill cases against
prosecutors perpetrators the app can be
used with a digital camera allowing
medical professionals to supplement
their written reports with photographs
of key evidence such as physical
bruising for this evidence to be useful
countries need prosecutors who are
capable of building cases upon such
evidence and judges with the
independence to punish powerful
perpetrators yet these are basic
institutions that many countries
including the Democratic Republic of
Congo still lack and this is why in June
secretary Kerry announced a new
accountability initiative to support
specialized justice sector mechanisms
such as mobile courts to improve access
to justice for survivors of sexual and
gender-based violence in conflicts and
to help build the judicial capacity of
partner governments as you all know the
struggle for accountability must not
only be waged in conflict zones like the
Congo but also here in the United States
including at our colleges and
universities an estimated one in five
women has been sexually assaulted during
her college years of those assaults only
12% are reported and of those reported
assaults only a fraction of the
offender's are punished that is why
President Obama established the White
House Task Force to protect students
from sexual assaults in April the task
force released a report with recommended
steps that schools can take to hold
offenders accountable and support
survivors this struggle needs to be
waged not only by women but also by men
that's one of the messages behind the
Presidents and vice presidents it's on
us campaign launched recently to stop
sexual assault on college campuses as a
proud Yale graduate I'm often amazed by
the leadership and the service of Yale
students and graduates but rarely am i
as impressed as I have been with how
students here have taken up this
challenge moving far beyond making a
pledge to bringing together leaders from
across campus from Yale's College
Council to communication and consent
educators from the Yale Women's Center
to sports teams and acapella groups to
build a campaign that makes everyone on
this campus ask how can we change our
behavior and our community to live up to
the
pledge how can we work with the
administration to bring about stronger
enforcement and accountability how do we
make this part of our Yael that's
exactly what it's on us is all about
at the same time far from us campuses we
have to make un peacekeepers better at
protecting women and girls from sexual
violence one way to do that is by
improving early warning systems for
sexual violence and other atrocities and
proactively pursuing repeat offenders
peacekeepers in the Congo have set up
alert networks that allow communities to
report threats and attacks in real time
directly to UN peacekeeping bases so
they can intervene and the UN created a
special unit in its Congo mission the
force intervention Brigade which has
made real headway disarming and
defeating the armed groups responsible
for some of the worst atrocities
including mass rape yet the sad fact is
that even when peacekeepers are warned
they often fail to act a March report by
the UN's internal oversight office found
that in 507 attacks against civilians
from 2000 to 2013 peacekeepers virtually
never use force to protect civilians
under attack this is totally
unacceptable to address the problem the
United States is working to ensure
peacekeepers have both the capacity and
the will to protect civilians under
attack in August President Obama
announced the African peacekeeping Rapid
Response partnership or a prep which
will invest 110 million dollars each
year for the next three to five years to
build the capabilities of six countries
Ethiopia Ghana Rwanda Senegal Tanzania
and Uganda which have embraced a more
robust approach to peacekeeping and we
are building a global consensus among
all peacekeeping countries including the
most skeptical ones about the critical
importance of actually implementing
civilian protection mandates including
by protecting women and girls that is
what the short game looks like in
stopping sexual violence against women
and girls but of course if we want to
move beyond protecting women and girls
from abuses to empowering them to
realize their full potential we need to
do much more it will come as no surprise
to you that education is the linchpin of
our
game in women women's and girls
empowerment we know that education is a
smart investment not only in the girls
future but also in the future of their
nations as countries that do a better
job of educating girls are on average
more prosperous healthier more
democratic and more peaceful that is not
a coincidence
yet while it is all well and good to say
we need to ensure girls right to an
education and educating girls is one of
the smartest investment societies can
make getting girls into the classroom
and keeping them there through secondary
school takes much more than making
school compulsory or building classrooms
just look at the numbers 62 million
girls worldwide are not in school more
than 30 million of them in sub-saharan
Africa where there is so much promise
to tackle this problem we need to change
the mental models attitudes and
behaviors that lie beneath this
persistent imbalance
for instance in Tanzania four out of
every ten girls are married before their
18th birthday that's because according
to a recent report by Human Rights Watch
many communities across the country see
marriage as a way to protect girls from
premarital sex and pregnancy both of
which are seen as undermining a family's
honor in addition as we know brides
families received our ease from groom's
families giving them a strong incentive
to marry their daughters early as the
result girls are married off young
forcing many to leave school and even
those who stay in school after marriage
are often pressured by school
administrators and family members to
drop out when they become pregnant girls
who marry early are more vulnerable to a
range of other abuses including domestic
violence and marital rape it is
impossible to ensure more girls in
Tanzania find their seats in the
classroom and hold on to them without
these societies tackling the underlying
beliefs and practices that are driving
girls from school that means changing
attitudes and communities about child
marriage and dowries and convincing
educators to find ways to allow pregnant
girls to continue their studies behind
every one of the obstacles to girls
education is a fear or prejudice that we
must address it is fear of empowered
women that drives extremist groups
to abduct girls from their classrooms as
they did with the chibok schoolgirls in
Nigeria and fear that drove them to try
to kill this year's remarkable Nobel
Prize winner Malala yousufzai for daring
to champion girls right to an education
in Pakistan and it is deep-seated
prejudice that causes families to see
educating their daughters as less
important than educating their sons the
only way to overcome these obstacles to
empowerment is to challenge the
dangerous idea that a girl's education
is a privilege or even a threat rather
than what we know it to be which is a
right in some instances changes in the
belief systems underlying these
practices can be fostered by public
policies in West Bengal for example a
political affirmative action program put
women leaders in village government for
the first time within seven years men's
individual bias against the capacity of
women leaders almost fully disappeared
seeing women leaders in positions of
authority also gave parents higher
aspirations for their daughters and
raised girls expectations for themselves
and we know full well that the developed
world needs public policy oriented
around girls and women's empowerment as
well last week Germany passed
legislation requiring the country's
leading companies to have at least 30
percent of the membership on their
executive boards be held by women up
from the current level of approximately
7% this in a country led by a female
Chancellor with a parliament that is
approximately 40 percent female which is
more than double the proportion in the
US Congress when we invest in empowering
women and girls the results come
full-circle
women and girls who are better educated
can demand more accountable justice
systems which are more effective at
prosecuting cases of sexual violence
they will also be better informed about
their rights and thus be better equipped
to defend them and to demand redress
when they are violated it makes her a
virtuous positive feedback loop by
investing in empowering women and girls
we help create societies where the
sexual violence against them is less
likely to occur by playing the long game
reduce the need to play a short game now
I've spoken to you about the importance
of looking beyond stopping the current
Ebola outbreak to how we can prevent
similar outbreaks in the future and I've
spoken about how in addition to taking
immediate steps to end sexual violence
we also need to invest more fully in
women's and girls empowerment in both
instances the threat in front of us is
so urgent and the suffering it causes is
so devastating that it can be easy to
lose sight of long-term investments this
problem of being consumed by responding
to the here and now of a crisis is
especially acute with regard to the
final threat that I want to discuss
violent extremism the violence and
suffering caused by violent extremist
groups calls out for our immediate
response making it particularly
challenging to maintain a focus on the
long term in a time when we wonder if we
have lost our capacity to feel horror
the barbarism of these groups continues
to sicken us in its vicious campaign
against the Yazidi people ISIL continues
to abduct women and girls hold them
captive and rape them systematically
before auctioning them off like cattle
at markets last week in northern Nigeria
in a series of attacks bearing the
hallmarks of Boko Haram forty five
people were killed by two suicide
bombers in a crowded marketplace and at
least 120 people were killed by bombs
and gunmen in an attack on a major
mosque it goes without saying that
because terrorist groups like ISIL pose
a threat to Americans and to
international peace and security we must
rally other nations to confront them
this is why in May the president
launched the counterterrorism
partnership fund at West Point to build
the capacity of our partners on the
frontlines in this shared effort and why
the United States has rallied over 60
partners to a global coalition to
degrade and defeat ISIL many of these
partners are already contributing in
concrete ways whether through military
support or through addressing the
humanitarian catastrophes that isil's
terror has helped create another
critical part of responding to this
threat is stopping the flow of foreign
fighters who increasingly fill the ranks
of these extremist groups
suicide bombers not only from Fallujah
but also from Florida fighters not only
from Peshawar but from Paris it is
estimated that more than 16,000 foreign
fighters from more than 90 countries
have traveled to Syria since the
conflict began sixteen thousand people
and this includes many people who hold
American and EU passports President
Obama has taken the lead in addressing
the threat posed by foreign terrorist
fighters in September he chaired a UN
Security Council summit at the UN on
this problem in which Member States
committed to taking decisive steps
including stopping the flow of funding
and enacting national laws to make it
more difficult for these fighters to
join such conflicts but if we do not
play the long game in addressing the
hatred fueling these groups and the
reasons individuals are drawn to their
ideology the waves of extremists will
keep coming here Syria off offers an
important lesson because when we look at
the Syrian conflict we are reminded that
isil's barbarism has been fueled by the
barbarism of the Assad regime a regime
whose ongoing atrocities continue to be
isil's most fertile recruiting tool a
regime that during Ramadan calibrated
its bombing runs to coincide with the
times and places where Muslims were
meeting to break the fast a regime that
dropped chemical weapons and barrel
bombs on unarmed civilians a regime that
is responsible for torturing thousands
of detainees and documenting their
torment in harrowing photographs whose
victims were given serial numbers and
and their torture starvation and
killings meticulously documented so
those who argue that we must work with
the Assad regime to vanquish the threat
of ISIL are wrongheaded about this being
productive for American interests not
only would partnering with Assad go
against what America stands for and
believes in it would be a huge boon for
extremism in the region and the world in
Syria the enemy of our enemy is not and
will never be our friend
the lesson to be drawn from the Syrian
conflict is one that can be applied far
beyond its borders extremism thrives in
places where people have no hope where
brutality is systematized where impunity
is and
extremism grows in dark places where
there is no hope or light to let other
ambitions grow tackling violent
extremism also requires lifting up the
voices of Muslims and people of all
faiths who denounce terrorist acts
committed in the name of Islam in
September 126 Muslim scholars sent a
letter to the head of ISIL saying it is
forbidden in Islam to kill the innocent
it is forbidden in Islam to kill
emissaries ambassadors and diplomats
hence it is forbidden to kill
journalists and aid workers it is
forbidden in Islam to harm or mistreat
in any way Christians or any people of
the scripture it is obligatory to
consider the Yazidis as people of the
scripture the reintroduction of slavery
is forbidden in Islam now I didn't hear
about this letter when it came out and
chances are neither did you and neither
did so many people particularly in the
Muslim world to whom the letter is also
directed I first heard about it a few
weeks ago when the UN High Commissioner
for Human Rights Zeid Raad al-hussein
also a Muslim read it before the
Security Council he also told the
Council of isil's attacks quote the
authors of these crimes are people whose
actions are nothing but disgusting and
whose consciences have demonstrably been
annihilated and quote more messages like
the clerics and like the High
Commissioners need to be heard in
addition to lifting up the voices of
Muslims who denounce terrorism we also
have to close the detention facility at
Guantanamo Bay the facility should never
have been opened in the first place and
continues to make us less safe and to
undermine our standing in the world
years ago the Supreme Court rejected the
premise for opening Gitmo which was that
detainees would not be able to challenge
their detention the vast majority of
detainees once held at Guantanamo have
been transferred including 530
transferred under the previous
administration as a US diplomat I can't
tell you how often other governments
point to Gitmo as a way of defending
their repressive practices or how much
it's sustained
existence continues to weigh on our
relationships with close partners and
allies and extremist groups continue to
use Guantanamo as a propaganda tool to
recruit those who seek to do us harm
and as a justification for their
abhorrent violence President Obama has
made clear his desire to close
Guantanamo but since 2009 Congress has
imposed restrictions that have
constrained our ability to do so
including placing limits on our ability
to transfer detainees to foreign
countries and imposing a prohibition on
transferring details detainees to the
United States even those we have the
capacity to effectively prosecute for
their crimes another argument should not
be necessary but please listen to this
one
the United States is spending nearly
half a billion dollars annually to
operate the detention facility which
currently holds 142 detainees that works
out to roughly three million dollars per
day teen per detainee per year or
approximately thirty times what it costs
to hold a prisoner in a federal supermax
prison the kind of facility from which
no prisoner has ever escaped that same
half a billion dollars could be spent
training nurses to stop the spread of
Ebola in West Africa or investing in
girls education in Nigeria or
Afghanistan or strengthening aviation
security and information-sharing tools
to track down foreign terrorist fighters
or any of the other long-term
investments domestic or international
that too often gets short shrift now at
times it can feel as though the United
States is shouldering an unfair burden
in responding to global threats and that
the American people are the only ones
being asked to make sacrifices to try to
ensure a more secure and stable world
but we are not we live in a world full
of people willing to put everything on
the line for the future of their
families their Nations and by extension
for the world that we share that
dedication is what drove so many of the
young Liberians guineans in Sierra
Leoneans that I met on my recent trip
people risking their lives as well as
alienation from their communities by
volunteering to serve in the Ebola
treatment centers and in the burial
teams
as one young volunteer told me in
Freetown the capital of Sierra Leone
quote if we leave our brothers and
sisters to die who knows it might be us
next it is a point of duty and quote it
is what continues to drive schoolgirls
in northern Nigeria to show up to class
every day girls who are not willing to
let the fear of seeing other girls
kidnapped by extremists keep them from
claiming their right to an education and
it is what drove the fearless Libyan
human rights defender Sawa bias to stand
up for the rights of her people despite
constant death threats first under the
Qadhafi regime and later from extremists
on June 25th 2014 Sawa urged her fellow
Libyans not to be intimidated by
extremists who had threatened to attack
anyone who voted in parliamentary
elections she even posted photos of
herself casting her ballot on her
Facebook page to show that she would not
be cowed by the death threats she had
received or by fear she was killed that
night all of these people The Jacksons
and the SOL was in the Nigerian school
girls and so many others are our
partners in the long game and they have
high expectations not just for
themselves but for us they believe that
the United States will live up to our
highest principles by standing with them
they believe that we will prove worthy
of wielding the tremendous
responsibility that comes with our
tremendous power that we will not only
play the long game because it is in our
self-interest which it is but because we
believe it is right to advance the
dignity of people around the world which
it is it is and must be a constant
struggle for all of us to live up to
these expectations and to live up to
these principles in the United States
and abroad people recognize that this is
a struggle that the American people have
embraced and that we who have the
privilege of representing them must
embrace as well it is the constant
struggle that makes us who we are it is
why our partners and the world expects
so much of us and that is not a burden
that weighs us down
it is a wind that lifts us up thank you
thank you very much
I'm Jeff Brundle I'm the master of
Timothy Dwight college and the steward
of the Chubb fellowship and knowing the
stress and strain of ambassador powers
work not to mention the relentless sense
of urgency that rises up to meet her
every day I'm both impressed and
grateful that she came today to
participate in a class here with Paul
Gruber it's Jake Sullivan and Harold Koh
has stayed to give this University chalk
fellowship address and we'll have dinner
later with a hundred and twenty
undergraduates and the reception I like
what she said then about the long game
Hendon chub and the many prior chuck
fellows would applaud her investment
here today in you and in us I hope she
will see a return on the investment both
from those inside and those outside this
room were privileged to have her here
were privileged in general and that
privilege brings its obligations let's
hope that we can seize our opportunities
in the ways that she has seized hers so
let's have a few questions you see two
microphones here in the aisle if you
have a question please make your way to
those microphones now some of you are
positioned advantageously for this and
because time is short please do your
best to speak briefly and ask a clear
question okay thanks very much and
Nicola because you're a TD student we'll
start with you thank you very much miss
power and a recent profile unit of you
in the Vogue magazine and has a friend
and a cut former colleague of you you're
saying people at Samantha's moral
compass and compassion don't usually
make it to such ranks of power and my
question follows on from that I've
always respected your ability to
criticize governments and other bodies
both abroad and at home and in the US
but you're busy
now as a representative for the US
requires I assume that you defend and
promote the US is the position of the US
and even when it might be against or
different to your own personal position
or even when it is criticized by other
human rights organizations and I wanted
to know if you could please speak to the
challenges holding such a position with
such constraints versus say being an
independent journalist great thank you
easy one yeah I was hoping when when the
question started by quoting Vogue I was
hoping we were trending in a good
direction but let me let me just I think
the best way to answer it is just to
describe the the blessing of that I feel
everyday being particularly in the job
that I'm in now getting to represent the
United States I'm an Irish immigrant to
this country getting to sit in front of
the placard having the weight of our
diplomatic resources and our means and
our soft power behind me every day on
behalf of the same causes I champion my
entire life from you know the basement
of by Nicky library you know wherever
wherever I was working on a given day I
mean in the in the old days when I wrote
a column for instance I used to have a
column at Time magazine or if I wrote a
long New Yorker piece my hope was that
someone at a much lower level than mine
now would read that and would bring it
into the meetings and try to inject a
perspective from the field from the
weight you know from people who could
speak to the ways in which policies were
affecting real people far from as it
were the boardroom or far from the
bureaucracy so I just feel very
incredibly privileged to be able to take
that perspective and I just give you a
couple examples of how I think bridging
those worlds is can be can be really
powerful and important one I mentioned
already Jackson Nima
the Security Council occasionally brings
in people from outside UN officialdom
but relatively rarely still and when we
did this meeting for the first again
emergency meeting on a public health
crisis in the 70 year history of the UN
there'd been a really important AIDS
Security Council meeting before but to
think how you puncture what people are
bringing the preexisting alibis and and
and biases and indifference or even
concern but but misinformation or
whatever that people are bringing to
their to this meeting and to find a
Liberian health worker who actually was
the person at the gates having to turn
people away because there just weren't
enough beds and for him to describe what
it was like to tell a father that no he
could not deposit his child in the
council if I have the chance as the UN
ambassador to bring Jackson's voice into
UN Security Council deliberations which
are usually you know a little more
robotic I mean that's that is and if the
price is simply that having argued for
something internally and not succeeded
that that I you know get to go out and
still defend the US I mean that's a very
modest price to play another example is
we pushed the Obama administration
pushed hard to try to get the crimes in
Syria referred to the International
Criminal Court and Russia cast its
fourth veto in the Syria context over
that issue and you know when I was
sitting down with my team to think about
how can we capture the stakes of this
and this is an not a story of success
from a policy standpoint but nonetheless
there all of these people out there in
Syria who've been barrel bombed by this
regime and tortured have been gassed
with sarin and and now with this veto
that's coming tomorrow the Russians
won't it will prevent those crimes from
ever being or from for the time being
anyway being adjudicated or prosecuted
in court so we tracked down chemical
weapons survivor and I was able to say
to the council and to
my Russian colleague and chinese
colleague also vetoed you know
unfortunately because of these vetoes
today the icc will not be able to hear
the testimony of people who survived the
chemical weapons attacks it would be
left to a court normally to decide what
is true and what is false but here is
the testimony of one person who would
have liked to testify and i just in his
own voice basically described what had
happened to him and he and brought we we
ended up being able to bring him into
the security council chamber and he and
others again it's small compared to the
veto which was so devastating but that
to be able to inject that perspective
into deliberations again is the
privilege of a lifetime
the to writing a column and again hoping
someone will read my column i take this
any day in thinking about the long run
is US diplomacy doing anything to
separate the followers from the
leadership of the terrorist group and
somehow welcoming them back into civil
society it's an excellent question i
mean i think that there are a number of
programs now that exists including a
very noteworthy one in the UAE which is
which is for people who have chosen to
leave violent extremist groups and i
think thinking through not only the
pressure side of the equation namely
what are the disincentives you know what
are the rewards that can be placed for
the arrest or capture of individuals who
are behind very nefarious plotting but
thinking about how to pull away those
followers whether through social media
and places that they're very very active
to try to right now the the terrorists
in isil have taken significant advantage
of social media platforms and it's
really important that we who are trying
to contest that message but not just we
the the kinds of clerics that that i
described in in my remarks that they are
taking advantage of those platforms as
well and pulling them away
so we're drawing on on everything in the
department of homeland security in the
Department of Justice across the US
government in terms of the State
Department our public diplomacy to try
to project messages of the kind that
you're describing which is that there is
a place to go and and that you're not
you know that at a certain point you're
not too far gone on the other hand if
people have been part of executing
American journalists and you know the
kinds of horrors that have been
perpetrated in Syria and Iraq you know
we also have responsibilities
particularly to American citizens to
pursue prosecution and so forth so you
know I think separating out people who
have been instrumental in violent acts
against civilians from those who sort of
thought it might be a cool idea to go to
Syria for you know their their school
break and then got stuck there we need a
way and to continue to strengthen the
ways of distinguishing ambassador could
you comment on the United Nations
conference on climate change that
starting this week in Lima Peru and also
give us your projection as to how that
the result of that conference might be
implicated implemented by the President
and by the Congress thank you
well one of the the reasons that
President Obama and the Chinese premier
made the announcement that they did when
they did was to try to inject into that
conference momentum out of the bilateral
agreement that we reached with China and
I will say now is a somewhat of a
veteran of multilateral diplomacy having
worked on it for four plus years at the
White House and now being in been in my
current job for more than a year the
often the the the the best ingredient
for successful multilateral diplomacy is
strong bilateral agreements that then
amalgamate
and so you know you know for the United
States and China to make commitments of
that nature
not only in terms of emissions
reductions as the two largest economies
as the two major emitters but also for
the United States to make such a
substantial commitment on the funding
side for those countries that are
already feeling the effects of climate
change and there's just the the cost and
I hear this from small island countries
at the UN and it's as poignant as
hearing about abuses carried out in in
peacekeeping is just hearing whole
villages disappear livelihoods
eradicated and so forth so we attempted
to bring that momentum into Peru I'm not
going to make any predictions because
these conferences are very hard to
predict but we have a number of bites at
the Apple between now and and you know
the ultimate goal for something more
comprehensive thank you um well first
I'd like to thank you for giving such a
convincing argument for why the United
States should play a role in supporting
liberty and freedom in the world but my
question is that you talked a lot about
the like if not for tests and evaluating
humanitarian interventions and a lot of
these Wars like Iraq and some of the
other ones have been billed as
humanitarian have given humanitarianism
as a bad name and have made the American
people understandably frustrated with
you know excursions for an experience so
can you explain it how you think well
you and the government in general or the
Obama ministration or future
administrations can convince people see
or convince the American people that the
United States has a role to play in the
world beyond just protecting its
national security well I think first of
all we have to to pull apart the like
and the unlike and and try it's very
challenging to do this but you know try
to distinguish one particular set of
circumstances from another so for
instance the circumstances that gave
rise that existed prior to the
war in Iraq back in 2003 were ones that
President Obama been you know of course
not president but nonetheless
did not find convincing as warranting
the deployment of US forces and an
intervention without Security Council
authorization and a lot of the the sort
of force seen negative international
reaction which I believe as he put it at
the time was going to have implications
on the back end also for how much
support one would get in sort of seeing
through the mission that is a very
different set of circumstances from the
set of circumstances where ISIL a group
with that makes very explicit its
genocide all intention toward Shia
toward Christians toward ezd forcing
people to convert raping people
enslaving people executing American
journalists who they know have done no
harm other than to try and document the
suffering of the Syrian people so
drawing those distinctions yes it turns
out there are military operations in
both instances in Iraq but there are
also substantial difference in terms of
the the imminent threat posed by in the
case of the the current effort by you
know something that we haven't seen
before which is a terrorist movement
controlling large swaths of territory
and massive heavy weaponry you know much
of which its oil fields right I mean so
it's again just to to isolate both the
intentions the actions and the resources
and capabilities of this movement and
and make the case on those grounds and I
think notwithstanding the very very
understandable fatigue in this country
from being involved in war for so long
in Iraq and Afghanistan the support the
public support for this effort against
ISIL I think speaks to the fact that
that distinction was drawn and the
people accept that these are two
different circumstances it doesn't mean
that they're not
concerned that they don't raise issues
that have to be taken very very
seriously about you know ending up in a
different place but in terms of this
again campaign in support of Iraqi
efforts to to rollback isil's gains and
ultimately degrade and defeat ISIL
there's that there's a lot of support
the other thing we need to do though
that I tried to do a little bit tonight
but we need to do more of is when
something is working as for instance our
intervention in Liberia is is working
it's not succeeded it's not close to
having succeeded but it is having
measurable demonstrable effects for
families in Liberia and ultimately
having important effects also for the
security the American people we need to
be sure that we are communicating that
effectively to the American people you
know it is it is unfortunate somebody
who who has maybe some bandwidth to do
this can can look at this but you know
the amount of coverage that the Ebola
epidemic got in the in the period where
before our interventions in Liberia
started to take effect versus the amount
of coverage that I mean again it's
normal but but it's not desirable from
the standpoint of the American people
actually knowing the return on the
investment that they are getting by
virtue of what our heroic forces and CDC
epidemiologists and aid workers and
diplomats are doing I mean so we have to
tell that story and I try to do that
wherever I can but that's a part I think
of ensuring that the American people
have confidence not only in the that we
have the right objective as the
government but also that we have the
ability to achieve the objectives that
we lay out and that that confidence is
an important part of sustaining our
international engagement okay I'm going
to apologize for the folks that have
been standing in line because I think
we're going to be able to do two more
questions so why don't we hear from
everyone
and I'll just take a couple of them and
at least your your fellow audience
members will have heard from them
alright rapid-fire rapid-fire you spoke
a little bit about how important it is
for the United States to partner with
other nations to promote peace and
security how do you find how do you deal
with the challenge of balancing trying
to cooperate with countries like Russia
or China that we agree with on some
issues and want to work with but then on
the issue of Syria or in Ukraine or the
conflicts in the South China Sea we
diverge how do you balance those two
different issues yes after hearing you
talk about the obstacles to women's
education outside the US I can't help
but just feel amazingly lucky to get to
go to school you know at all and
especially at a place like this and I'm
wondering if you know given all the
experience alluring that has happened
for you between the time you graduated
Yale and where you are now is there
anything you learned here either
academically or socially this really
made an impact and how you do your job
I'm wondering if you can comment on the
future of the responsibility to protect
doctrine given the challenges of
intervening in Syria to great historical
events in my life when I met my wife
that was the number one and number two
the formation of the United Nations can
you give us some idea of what's going on
to make the United Nations a more
efficient and organization in terms of
reforms of various types I appreciated
your words about global threats
requiring global cooperation in the
context of Ebola or fighting the threat
from returning foreign fighters I'm
wondering what you think in the next few
decades will be the challenges limits
and benefits of empowering regional
partnerships not just in the US and
India or direct bilateral relations for
things like the climate deal but
directly empowering regional powers to
be presences in their regions and to
deal with some of the
and issues and guide in ways that the
u.s. may not be able to or willing to in
the next coming decades first of all I
wanted to say thank you because I know
you're a big inspiration to me and
probably many in this room I've heard
world fellow Romney Nakhla who's a an
activist in Syria speak frequently on
this semester about the nature of the
ISIS problem being not just something
that's a short-term solution but as you
said long gamed and something it relates
very strongly to the power vacuum in
Syria so I was wondering if you could
talk more about what the frontier is on
that issue because most of what I've
heard is very cynical and that it's just
something that's going on but I know
that you've written obviously about how
America responds in the age of genocide
and what you think the next step is so
you spoke a little bit about how Islam
does not support the actions of Isis and
so I was wondering why we're still
calling it Isis and rewarding it by
branding it with the name you know of a
religion that supports you know that's a
good relation with good people so just
thank you ambassador thank you for B
would have us call it Islamic state they
would they would have us call it I mean
that is their their current title for
themselves but I mean go ahead sorry
with the Millennium Development Goals
set to expire and the sustainable
development goals being next on the
agenda I'm wondering what you see is the
greatest challenge in those negotiations
and which countries the United States is
going to need to engage to achieve its
objectives you so much for being here
ambassador given that 2015 is the 100th
anniversary of the Armenian Genocide I'm
wondering what your feelings are on how
the UN will approach that and whether
this will be a time to bring up more or
less publicity about genocide in general
and whether this anniversary is an
important thing for Americans to also be
aware of given that there's a larger
median population but also given the
many other genocides that have happened
since that time um hi my question is
more about your background
you were a journalist and you were just
had just graduated from Yale when the
u.s. lobbying genocide began you saw the
Rwandan genocide and you saw the UN
system fail and now as being part of
that system how does that inform your
role in the UN particularly with
intervention mm-hmm thank you so much
for being here my own studies have
focused on jet promotion Aranda which
have been to a degree successful through
a combination of the country size
political well and the fact that it's
post-conflict of course you look at
places like the DRC where violence and
conflict themselves have become endemic
how do you combat kind of gender-based
violence in those situations thank you
my question is about genocide also I
count probably two major instances in
the current administration of the word
genocide being used very publicly and
very impactfully in Benghazi and then
earlier this year
surrounding the UCD's in Iraq and I
would like you to just maybe briefly
give a retrospective grading on the
administration's use of that term and
whether it kind of fits in the model
that you would think is appropriate for
the use of that term and whether or not
you think it's maybe broader than just
one president or one administration and
if it reflects a broader institutional
change
by the US government and the way it uses
that term and how that term is used to
affect broader action in the world thank
you ambassador I just want a question
how can the u.s. alongside the United
Nations block any future military
intervention and military kind of I
would say a war kind of between the
Israelis and the Palestinians how can we
block a future Israeli raid on Gaza and
killing civilians thank you so
ambassador power I'm gonna be deeply
impressed by the way that you pulled
this off and I know that in advance and
and also I think we've got enough
material here for another visit next
week don't you think okay first let me
say one reason I think that was the
right thing to do is just what an
amazing amazing group of students
definitely the standards have gone up
since they let me in so it's not one of
those questions I would have been
capable of asking when I was here as an
undergrad but nonetheless now I'm stuck
answering them so let me what I think
I'll do is just I'm actually not gonna
try to tick on each of them but I will I
want to just say a few words about the
issues that haven't come up yet so far
and then just encourage those students I
don't recall exactly where we're going
next but we have some next on the
Grateful Dead tour we're making our way
to the next venue and then people who
don't feel I was responsive to their
question I'm more than happy to engage
but one because I think it's a question
the very first question one about how we
continue to work everyday with Russia
notwithstanding Ukraine and Syria and
these very divisive issues I think it's
just a question that's been on a lot of
people's minds so I'll take that
question the I think the the the answer
is that each of us that the United
States and Russia each have interests
that we want to see advanced in Syria
for instance we our interests in that
are very much overlapping should be
overlapping with Russia's preventing
foreign terrorist fighters flow
preventing terrorist groups from gaining
a foothold preventing chemical weapons
use those are our interests and those
are why we have taken the policy
positions that we have very much
alongside preventing the slaughter of
innocent families which is happening
every day
Russia has at least some of those shared
interests but their route to advancing
those interests is
very distinct from ours and that is what
creates the clash that we have seen in
the vetoes that I've mentioned in other
words they view Assad as the route to
achieving many of the objectives that
I've described and sort of just
accepting his rule in perpetuity as
being in our collective interests which
they would characterize but at the same
time we are in gridlock in the Security
Council over Syria we are working side
by side in the p5 plus 1 negotiations to
try to come up with a comprehensive deal
that would deny Iran a pathway to a
nuclear weapon and Russia has
participated constructively in that by
the same token on many many Africa
issues whether South Sudan or the
Central African Republic or Mali you
know they you know issues where their
immediate interests may not be at stake
but they still vote in support of
peacekeeping operations or in support
even of sanctions designations and so
forth so there's a fair amount of
cooperation on issues not related to
Syria and Ukraine
that goes on in New York and it's very
useful for our interests that that is
the case our cooperation the Security
Council will never lead us to pull our
punches however on human rights abuses
inside Russia and the kinds of the kind
of over brazen aggression that we've
seen in Ukraine so there are tensions in
all of that as you can imagine in terms
of just flagging a couple a couple other
things that hadn't come up the the I
think the Millennium Development Goals
is something a lot of students on campus
or we're interested in have
and got a lot of traction these goals
for kids being in school for malaria for
you know a whole host of social and
economic goods and they've had a
stickiness particularly in the health
area that has been very very important
our biggest challenge in negotiating the
successor goals to the MDGs is the
success of the MDGs because because
these goals became actionable and
resources have been deployed around a
set of goals measurable targets if you
have an issue that matters to you and
you're in this negotiation you want that
issue represented in the new set of
goals because you believe that it will
mean that you get the resources that you
need and every country is is bringing
this kind of attitude to it in other
words the stakes are seen as extremely
high but the results right now is a very
very long list and he who fights every
battle risks fighting none so the
biggest challenge is because of the
success perversely of the MDGs and the
faith that people have injected in this
new process it will be challenging very
challenging to discipline the list the
last thing I'd say just in terms of what
I learned academically or socially but I
I would say I mean the main that the
amazing thing about being at Yale was
opening up we used to have this thing
this is ridiculous that this is no
longer the case but we used to have the
Blue Book and opening up the Blue Book
store yeah but it's online doesn't count
you're the same just this it would come
and it was this amazing euphoric
experience where your eyes were so much
bigger than your tummy and you wanted to
take everything and learn everything and
inject yourself into a whole host of
domains that you had no business being
in in some cases but I think that's the
spirit that spirit of believing that you
can both learn
you know which can be a burden it's hard
particularly in competitive environments
like this one and love it I think that
is the thing that I that I took from
here and I've just been extremely
privileged in my professional career to
constantly learn and also just love it
and bring that expectation every day
that we can be inspired by our work and
even if we're not succeeding always in
just the way we like that to be to have
the privilege of trying is you know just
a great great blessing so the Blue Book
spirits that I take to my my day job I
think is what I would share anyway with
that thank you very much